This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I love podcasts, but like many people who work in this industry, my first love was the radio. I got my start working at my college radio station, WOBC 91.5, at Oberlin College. My musical taste and sense of humor were shaped by the DJs at WFMU in New Jersey, and my professional radio career and this very show began at my favorite public radio station, KALW 91.7 here in the Bay Area. But there's a whole other radio universe that I have a lot less experience with. Shortwave radio is the less used but further reaching cousin of AM and FM.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我热爱播客，但和许多从事这个行业的人一样，我的初恋是广播。我的职业生涯始于我在奥柏林学院的大学广播电台 WOBC 91.5。我的音乐品味和幽默感是由新泽西州 WFMU 电台的 DJ 们塑造的，而我的职业广播生涯以及这档节目本身，都始于我最喜欢的公共广播电台——位于湾区的 KALW 91.7。但还有一个我接触较少的广播世界。短波广播是 AM 和 FM 的“表亲”，虽然使用率较低，但传播范围更广。
It requires a completely different radio set. Long before the internet, Shortwave connected people all across the globe instantaneously, and it became an information battleground and powerful propaganda tool. This week we are bringing you the first episode in the second season of The Divided Dial. It's a series from on the media and longtime 99PI contributor Katie Thornton. In season one, Katie explored the history of political talk radio and how the radical right came to dominate the airwaves in the US. But her new four part season is all about shortwave. I'll let Katie take it from here. This is my Zenith Trans-Oceanics.
它需要一套完全不同的无线电设备。早在互联网出现之前，短波就将全球各地的人们瞬间连接在一起，它成为了信息战场和强大的宣传工具。本周，我们将为您带来《分裂的表盘》（The Divided Dial）第二季的第一集。这是由《On the Media》节目组和《99PI》的长期撰稿人凯蒂·桑顿制作的系列节目。在第一季中，凯蒂探讨了政治谈话广播的历史，以及激进右翼是如何在美国广播界占据主导地位的。但她这一季的四集内容全是关于短波的。接下来交给凯蒂。这是我的真力（Zenith）跨洋收音机。
This is such a cool radio with the little... Last summer, I met up with a journalist and radio fan named David Gorin. These are like beautiful radios up here. I went to his house in Brooklyn, New York so that we could listen to the radio together. Not any old radio, not AM or FM, nothing you can pick up in your car, but shortwave radio, the little known cousin of AM and FM, with fuzzy stations that can reach insanely far distances. David's been listening to shortwave
这台收音机太酷了，还有那个小……去年夏天，我见了一位名叫大卫·戈林的记者和广播迷。这些收音机看起来真漂亮。我去了他位于纽约布鲁克林的家，这样我们就可以一起听广播了。不是普通的收音机，不是 AM 或 FM，不是你在车里能收到的那种，而是短波广播——AM 和 FM 的那个鲜为人知的表亲，有着能传到极远距离的模糊电台。大卫一直在听短波。
since he was a kid in the 70s, when his uncle gave him a radio. And I turned it on, and it's like the radio leapt out of my hand with the North American service of Radio Moscow. Suddenly, the world was all within reach, available to him right there in this box. In the seventh grade, I became the expert on the next five-year plan in the Soviet Union, the economic plan.
从 70 年代他还是个孩子，他叔叔送给他一台收音机开始。我打开它，感觉收音机就像从我手中跳出来一样，传出了莫斯科广播电台的北美服务节目。突然间，世界触手可及，就在这个盒子里。七年级时，我成了苏联下一个五年计划——那个经济计划——的专家。
— Today, he's part of the Library of Congress's radio preservation task force. And together, on a sweaty Thursday afternoon last July... — Quick and dirty. —...we sat down to hear what we could find on the shortwave dial today. Just like when David was a kid, we heard lots of government-run stations, like Radio Martini.
——如今，他是国会图书馆广播保护工作组的一员。去年七月一个闷热的周四下午，我们坐在一起……——简单粗暴。——……听听今天在短波表盘上能找到什么。就像大卫小时候一样，我们听到了许多政府运营的电台，比如马蒂广播电台（Radio Marti）。
The U.S. broadcasting news and information to Cuba. The Islamic Republic of Iran. China Radio International broadcasting in Spanish. Let's see, anything else strong? No, we're the big elite, broadcasting Italian. On other days, David has picked up English language shows from North Korea. They have very strident, you know, military stuff. And news from Cuba.
美国向古巴广播新闻和信息。伊朗伊斯兰共和国。中国国际广播电台用西班牙语广播。看看，还有什么信号强的吗？没有，我们是精英大台，在广播意大利语。在其他日子里，大卫还收到过来自朝鲜的英语节目。他们有非常刺耳的、你知道的，军事方面的内容。还有来自古巴的新闻。
This is Radio Rebel Day, Radio Rebel. And it goes back to the revolution. On the short waves, the global tussle for influence plays out 24-7. But we didn't just hear news and propaganda. Well, let's just go up to the dance. Let's hope I hear some worse crowd. There were beeps and bloops. Here we go.
这是“反叛电台日”，反叛电台。这可以追溯到革命时期。在短波上，全球的影响力争夺战 24 小时不停歇。但我们听到的不仅仅是新闻和宣传。好吧，让我们调到那个频道。希望我能听到一些更糟糕的杂音。那是哔哔声和嘟嘟声。开始了。
Coded messages sent between amateur radio operators, or between government officials who used the short waves to send military data or secret instructions. Let's see what else we have. And some of what we heard just sounded like normal radio, with lots of music, and preaching. ...strong in the Lord and the powers of might against the wiles of the devil. It was hidden just to hide the meaning of the power of the divine name. Oh yeah, that's not a world-time text voice. That's an End Times ministry that also pre inherent in the name of Yah.
业余无线电操作员之间，或者政府官员之间发送的加密信息，他们利用短波发送军事数据或秘密指令。看看我们还有什么。我们听到的一些内容听起来就像普通的广播，有很多音乐和布道。……在主里刚强，靠着大能大力，抵挡魔鬼的诡计。它被隐藏起来，只是为了掩盖神圣之名的力量含义。哦，是的，那不是世界时间文本语音。那是一个末日事工，也宣扬在雅威之名中固有的……
That's an End Times ministry that also preaches that the earth is flat. Which is very interesting because a shortwave radio wouldn't propagate in a flat earth, you know, but details, details. In just about an hour of surfing the short waves, we heard prayer and propaganda, news and conspiracy theories, so many languages, and some really decent jams from all over the globe. I felt like I had been welcomed into a club that was somehow secret and yet right there for anyone to join.
那是一个末日事工，也宣扬地球是平的。这很有趣，因为短波广播在平坦的地球上是无法传播的，你知道的，但细节嘛，细节。在短短一个小时的短波冲浪中，我们听到了祈祷和宣传、新闻和阴谋论、这么多语言，还有来自全球各地非常不错的音乐。我觉得自己被欢迎进入了一个俱乐部，它既神秘，又随时欢迎任何人加入。
And I know it's cliche, but there was something magical about tuning into the world, training my ear to listen through the crackle, hearing the distance. As it turns out, this practice of scanning the dial, finding out what you can hear and from how far away, is a century-old art. It was popular among radio's early adopters. These early distance fiends, as they were known, uncovered something very strange about how radio waves
我知道这很老套，但调频世界、训练耳朵穿过杂音去聆听远方的声音，确实有一种魔力。事实证明，这种扫描表盘、寻找能听到什么以及来自多远距离的练习，是一门百年艺术。它在广播的早期采用者中很受欢迎。这些早期的“距离狂热者”（正如他们所知）发现了一些关于无线电波如何穿过空间的非常奇怪的事情。
traveled through space. And what broadcasters did with that information? Completely altered the trajectory of the 20th century. This is season two of The Divided Dial. I'm your host, Katie Thornton. I've worked in radio since I was a teenager, sometimes behind the scenes, sometimes behind the mic. In season one, I investigated how right-wing talk took over AM and FM radio. But in all my years of radio research, I'd never really learned about shortwave radio before.
而广播公司利用这些信息做了什么？彻底改变了 20 世纪的轨迹。这是《分裂的表盘》第二季。我是主持人凯蒂·桑顿。我从十几岁起就在广播界工作，有时在幕后，有时在麦克风前。在第一季中，我调查了右翼谈话节目是如何接管 AM 和 FM 广播的。但在我多年的广播研究中，我以前从未真正了解过短波广播。
And listen, I'm not going to tell you that shortwave radio is as influential today as the AM and FM talk radio we covered in season one. It's not. But I, and I think you, love the medium of radio. So this season, we're diving into the often failed promise of a medium that was once ubiquitous, connecting people around the world long before the internet ever did.
听着，我不会告诉你短波广播在今天和我们在第一季中涵盖的 AM 和 FM 谈话广播一样有影响力。它没有。但我，我想你也一样，热爱广播这种媒介。所以这一季，我们将深入探讨一种曾经无处不在、在互联网出现之前就连接了世界各地人们的媒介，它那常常落空的承诺。
But like the internet, Shortwave also took a turn for the chaotic. Over the next four episodes, I'm going to explain how Shortwave radio became a propaganda tool for governments at war. And then a propaganda tool for American right-wing extremists and cults. And we'll explore what a little-known battle playing out on the shortwaves right now, between radio fanatics and Wall Street, can tell us about what happens when we cede control of our public airwaves.
但就像互联网一样，短波也走向了混乱。在接下来的四集里，我将解释短波广播是如何成为战争时期各国政府的宣传工具的。然后又如何成为美国右翼极端分子和邪教的宣传工具。我们将探讨目前在短波上上演的一场鲜为人知的战斗——广播狂热者与华尔街之间的较量——能告诉我们，当我们放弃对公共广播的控制权时会发生什么。
That's all coming up on this season of The Divided Dial. But let's get back to the story. Radio broadcasting, as in from one to many, it didn't start on shortwave. It started on AM, taking off around 1920, and AM was inherently local. Signals reached up to 50, maybe 75 miles. But at night, those listening at home noticed something strange. As the sun set, more stations emerged from the static.
这些内容都将在本季《分裂的表盘》中呈现。但让我们回到故事本身。广播，即从一到多的传播，并不是从短波开始的。它始于 AM，在 1920 年左右兴起，而 AM 本质上是本地化的。信号覆盖范围可达 50 到 75 英里。但在晚上，在家收听的人注意到了一些奇怪的事情。随着太阳落山，更多的电台从静电中浮现出来。
And they weren't coming from down the street or the next town over. Sometimes listeners in New York. Edison Studios, WAAM, located at one bond. Would hear stations from Chicago. — WCFL in Chicago. — A listener in Kansas might hear an opera or a boxing match from the East Coast.
它们不是来自街对面或隔壁城镇。有时纽约的听众——爱迪生工作室，WAAM，位于一邦德街——会听到来自芝加哥的电台。——芝加哥的 WCFL。——堪萨斯州的听众可能会听到来自东海岸的歌剧或拳击比赛。
—...body, and then Jim comes through with a one-pitch. — After dark, it was like the world cracked open, and distant stations faded in and out on ghostly, mysterious winds. Most people had never heard a faraway voice, period. Long-distance telephone calls were the costly domain of dignitaries and government officials, and even those were fed across long, scratchy copper lines. A disembodied voice, without a wire, without a fee,
——……身体，然后吉姆投出了一记一球。——天黑后，世界仿佛裂开了，遥远的电台在幽灵般神秘的风中忽隐忽现。大多数人从未听过远方的声音。长途电话是显贵和政府官员昂贵的特权，即使是那些电话也是通过长长的、沙沙作响的铜线传输的。一个没有电线、没有费用的离体声音，
from hundreds of miles away, that awed and baffled people. Even scientists, some of whom believed that radio, perhaps, could be used to communicate with the dead. But of course, there was an explanation for these voices in the night. Let us follow through the steps and the processes in transmitting or sending radio messages. Here's what was happening.
来自数百英里之外，这让人们感到敬畏和困惑。甚至科学家们，其中一些人认为无线电或许可以用来与死者交流。但当然，这些夜间的声音是有解释的。让我们跟随传输或发送无线电信息的步骤和过程。这就是当时发生的事情。
The way AM normally works is that radio waves get shot from the top of a tall tower, which is often on top of a tall hill. The radio messages leave the antenna as electromagnetic wave and travel with the speed of light. The waves travel over the ground, basically line of sight, from the tower to you. It's called a ground wave, and it's the thing that fades out a few dozen miles from The waves travel over the ground, basically line of sight, from the tower to you. It's called a ground wave, and it's the thing that fades out a few dozen miles from the tower. But when you shoot out an AM signal, there's another thing that happens, almost a byproduct.
AM 的正常工作方式是无线电波从高塔顶部发射，高塔通常位于高山之上。无线电信息作为电磁波离开天线，以光速传播。电波在地面上传播，基本上是视线范围内的，从塔到你。这被称为地波，它是在距离塔几十英里处就会消失的东西。但当你发射 AM 信号时，还会发生另一件事，几乎是一种副产品。
Radio waves are set up in all directions. It's called a sky wave, and the sky wave goes up into the atmosphere. The lower layers of the ionosphere, which are about 45 to 75 miles above the Earth's surface, they're like a huge sponge during the day and they absorb the signals that pass through them. Susan Douglas is a professor of communication and media at the University of Michigan. She says that these lower layers of the atmosphere are made up of ions that get all charged up by the sun. And in the daylight, those layers are where radio waves go to die.
无线电波向四面八方发射。这被称为天波，天波向上进入大气层。电离层的下层，距离地球表面约 45 到 75 英里，它们在白天就像一块巨大的海绵，吸收穿过它们的信号。苏珊·道格拉斯是密歇根大学传播与媒体教授。她说，大气层的这些下层是由被太阳充电的离子组成的。在白天，这些层是无线电波的“死亡之地”。
But at night, when the sun sets, these layers disappear and the ones above them, they combine to form a dense layer and it acts like a mirror to sky waves. At night, these sky waves, the sort of byproduct of AM transmission, they keep going until they bounce off this other layer of the ionosphere and they come back down to Earth vast distances away. When these waves strike the antenna of a receiving set, this entire process is reversed. We hear sound originating at that very moment, hundreds or even thousands of miles away. That's what these late night AM radio listeners
但在晚上，当太阳落山时，这些层消失了，它们上面的层结合形成了一个致密层，它就像天波的镜子。在晚上，这些天波（AM 传输的副产品）会一直传播，直到它们从电离层的这一层反弹回来，并回到距离遥远的地球表面。当这些波撞击接收设备的天线时，整个过程就会逆转。我们听到了那一刻发出的声音，来自数百甚至数千英里之外。这就是深夜 AM 广播听众
were hearing, a radio wave that had ricocheted off the ionosphere to get to them. And it rocked their world. Long distance channel surfing became a fad called Fishing in the Night, with listeners casting out into the ether and seeing what they could catch. They had a map on the wall
所听到的，一个从电离层反弹回来到达他们身边的无线电波。这震撼了他们的世界。长途频道冲浪成为了一种被称为“夜间垂钓”的时尚，听众们向以太中抛出鱼钩，看看能钓到什么。他们在墙上挂了一张地图，
with map tacks and every time they reeled in a station they would put a map tack on where that broadcast emanated from. Was it Kansas City? Was it Washington, D.C.? Wherever. and they would put a map tack on where that broadcast emanated from. Was it Kansas City? Was it Washington, D.C.? Wherever.
上面插着地图钉，每当他们钓到一个电台，就会在广播发出的地方插上一枚地图钉。是堪萨斯城吗？是华盛顿特区吗？无论哪里。
Radio manufacturers ran ads with slogans like, concerts from 14 cities in one evening. In newspaper editorials, distressed housewives and sometimes husbands lamented that their significant other was spending every evening out in their radio shack. But while AM broadcast listeners burned the midnight oil to marvel at all the faraway stations, there was one group of people who weren't so surprised by radio's ability to go long. They were the amateur radio operators, what you might know as ham radio. Basically guys who weren't broadcasting but were tinkering
无线电制造商打出的广告标语是：“一晚听遍 14 个城市的音乐会”。在报纸社论中，苦恼的家庭主妇（有时是丈夫）抱怨他们的另一半每天晚上都待在无线电室里。但是，当 AM 广播听众熬夜惊叹于所有遥远的电台时，有一群人对无线电的长距离传输能力并不感到惊讶。他们就是业余无线电操作员，也就是你可能知道的“火腿电台”（ham radio）。基本上，他们不是在广播，而是在摆弄
with radio equipment just to chat, one-to-one, like long-distance walkie-talkies. Back in the days before broadcasting, almost all radio transmission was one-to-one. The radio waves were mostly used by ship captains or the military, and the hams, who were just having fun. But in World War I, the U.S. government got worried about interference on those AM airwaves. So they eventually assigned specific frequencies for ships, for the military, and for those meddling amateurs.
无线电设备，只是为了聊天，一对一，就像长途对讲机一样。在广播出现之前的日子里，几乎所有的无线电传输都是一对一的。无线电波主要被船长或军方使用，而那些火腿族只是为了好玩。但在第一次世界大战中，美国政府开始担心 AM 频段上的干扰。因此，他们最终为船只、军方和那些爱管闲事的业余爱好者分配了特定的频率。
They were kicked down to the waves that were thought utterly worthless, short waves. Back then, people thought the short waves with short wavelengths — picture of really tight squiggly line — just wouldn't go very far. Even Guglielmo Marconi, the father of radio, thought that longer wavelengths would mean longer distances. But the amateurs weren't put off. They began experimenting with them.
他们被踢到了被认为毫无价值的波段——短波。当时，人们认为短波（波长短——想象一条非常紧密的波浪线）根本传不远。即使是无线电之父古列尔莫·马可尼也认为，更长的波长意味着更远的距离。但业余爱好者并没有被吓倒。他们开始用短波进行实验。
And as it turned out, the short waves weren't the short end of the stick. They were getting really far. They were getting stations in Australia and New Zealand, or stations in England and France. For the most part, reception was clearer at night, but it didn't have to be dark to go the distance. Amateurs reported spanning distances as great as 10,000 miles, which was unthinkable. Australia and New Zealand were described in the fall of 1923 as a bedlam of Yankee signals. The amateurs proved something huge.
事实证明，短波并不是“短板”。它们传得非常远。他们收到了澳大利亚和新西兰的电台，或者英国和法国的电台。在大多数情况下，晚上的接收效果更清晰，但并不一定要在黑暗中才能传得远。业余爱好者报告说，跨越的距离高达 10,000 英里，这在当时是不可想象的。1923 年秋天，澳大利亚和新西兰被描述为“洋基信号的喧嚣之地”。业余爱好者证明了一件大事。
Shortwave could do round the clock what AM could only do at night. It could use the ionosphere as a springboard. And this changed the game for AM broadcasters who wanted their station to reach more people. In 1923, Pittsburgh's KDKA, the country's first commercial radio station, they got their station on shortwave and reached as far as South Africa. New shortwave stations started up in Switzerland
短波可以全天候完成 AM 只能在晚上完成的事情。它可以利用电离层作为跳板。这改变了那些希望电台覆盖更多人的 AM 广播公司的游戏规则。1923 年，匹兹堡的 KDKA，全国第一家商业广播电台，将他们的电台搬上了短波，覆盖范围远至南非。新的短波电台在瑞士
and Japan and Venezuela. And with the scars of World War I still fresh, this burgeoning international medium was a source of hope. There was a lot of utopian discourse around radio that, you know, having allowed people to communicate across all these borders, you know, would there be no more wars? Michelle Hilms is a retired professor of media studies who has written a lot about radio. It would, you know, solve all kinds of problems. Just a huge enthusiasm over the possibilities of shortwave as a medium. Entire magazines were devoted to helping people discover new shows on international radio.
和日本以及委内瑞拉开始运营。随着第一次世界大战的伤痕依然新鲜，这种新兴的国际媒介成为了希望的源泉。当时围绕无线电有很多乌托邦式的论调，你知道的，让人们能够跨越所有这些边界进行交流，你知道的，会不会不再有战争了？米歇尔·希尔姆斯是一位退休的媒体研究教授，她写了很多关于广播的文章。它会，你知道的，解决各种各样的问题。人们对短波作为一种媒介的可能性充满了巨大的热情。整本整本的杂志致力于帮助人们发现国际广播上的新节目。
Listeners would write to far-flung stations, and the stations would reply with these beautifully decorated cards branded with the station name, and maybe some imagery that evoked the national culture of wherever they were broadcasting from. They're called QSL cards. It's international code for, I confirm receipt of your transmission.
听众会写信给遥远的电台，电台会回复这些装饰精美的卡片，上面印有电台名称，或许还有一些唤起他们广播所在地民族文化的图像。它们被称为 QSL 卡。这是国际通用代码，意思是“我确认收到您的传输”。
Shortwave listeners around the world amassed collections of these ornate cards, tangible evidence of their part in an ethereal global community. By the late 1930s, almost all home radio sets had AM and shortwave settings. But the peacenik aspirations for shortwave didn't last. It was the first time that human beings had had it in their power to be heard around the world and a lot of governments figured out that this could be a really powerful tool for the common good, but also, of course, for the waging of wars.
世界各地的短波听众收集了大量这些华丽的卡片，这是他们参与一个空灵的全球社区的有形证据。到 20 世纪 30 年代末，几乎所有的家用收音机都有 AM 和短波设置。但短波的和平主义愿望并没有持续太久。这是人类第一次有能力被全世界听到，许多政府意识到这可能是一个非常有力的工具，既可以造福大众，当然，也可以用于发动战争。
Lots of the world's governments had taken to the shortwaves by the 1930s, but no nation used them quite like Germany. This is Germany calling. We are going to present tonight a local play entitled, Visions of Invasion. Zeesen, Germany's state-run shortwave service, had spent years building a large following in America and around the world, playing things like orchestral music. But in time, they started pushing out Nazi propaganda,
到 20 世纪 30 年代，世界上许多政府已经开始使用短波，但没有哪个国家像德国那样使用它。这是德国在呼叫。今晚我们将呈现一部名为《入侵的幻象》的广播剧。齐森（Zeesen），德国的国有短波服务，多年来一直在美国和世界各地建立庞大的听众群，播放管弦乐等节目。但随着时间的推移，他们开始散布纳粹宣传，
tailored for specific countries in 12 different languages. And with its own festering Nazi movement, the US was a key target. You had people like Axis Sally. This is Berlin Calling. And I just like to say that when Berlin calls, it pays to listen.
针对特定国家，用 12 种不同的语言。由于美国国内存在着滋生的纳粹运动，美国成为了一个关键目标。你可能听说过像“轴心国萨利”（Axis Sally）这样的人。这是柏林在呼叫。我只想说，当柏林呼叫时，值得一听。
She was an American living in Berlin. She became the first American woman to be convicted of treason after the war that she was broadcasting into the United States on shortwave. Women of America waiting for the one you love, thinking of a husband who has been sacrificed by Franklin D. Roosevelt. You might have heard of a person called Lord Ha Ha. The great exodus from Britain is well underway. He was a British man named William Joyce who was working in Germany,
她是一个住在柏林的美国人。她在战后成为第一个因叛国罪被定罪的美国女性，因为她在短波上向美国广播。美国妇女们，等待着你们所爱的人，想着一个被富兰克林·D·罗斯福牺牲的丈夫。你可能听说过一个叫“哈哈勋爵”（Lord Haw-Haw）的人。英国的大撤离正在进行中。他是一个名叫威廉·乔伊斯的英国人，在德国工作，
broadcasting on their shortwave service. The rich and affluent are removing themselves from their value homes as fast as they can. There was also a big band called Charlie and his them, while removing themselves from their value bones, as fast as they can. There was also a big band called Charlie and his Orchestra, run by the German Ministry of Propaganda. They'd take popular big band and swing songs and add or change lyrics to berate Roosevelt or denigrate Jewish people. All the Jewish family has a brand new air. He's their joy heaven sent, and they proudly present Mr. Franklin D. Roosevelt Jones.
在他们的短波服务上广播。富人和权贵们正尽可能快地搬离他们有价值的家园。还有一个叫“查理和他的管弦乐队”的大乐队，由德国宣传部运营。他们会拿流行的爵士大乐队和摇摆乐歌曲，添加或修改歌词来抨击罗斯福或诋毁犹太人。所有的犹太家庭都有了一个全新的继承人。他是他们天赐的喜悦，他们自豪地呈现——富兰克林·D·罗斯福·琼斯先生。
Yes sir he is! They were trying to persuade Americans that the Germans had the right side in the war and that it was crazy for them to fight. Non-intervention, how he shows it, his decision to send troops along. The U.S. government had banned all editorializing on domestic radio stations during the war, making it illegal for Americans to promote the Nazi cause on the AM airwaves.
是的，先生，他就是！他们试图说服美国人，德国人在战争中站在正义的一方，他们参战是疯狂的。不干涉，他是如何展示的，他决定派遣军队……美国政府在战争期间禁止了国内广播电台的所有社论，使得美国人在 AM 广播上宣传纳粹事业成为非法。
But the feds didn't have any control over shortwave broadcasts beaming in from Germany. So the content was still there for the many Americans who wanted to listen. Journalists at CBS and NBC launched counteroffensives. The networks had what were called shortwave listening posts in New York. Susan Douglas again. And they had people who were fluent in foreign languages, monitoring international shortwave broadcasts.
但联邦政府对从德国传来的短波广播没有任何控制权。因此，对于许多想听的美国人来说，内容依然存在。哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）和美国全国广播公司（NBC）的记者发起了反击。这些电视网在纽约设有所谓的短波监听站。苏珊·道格拉斯再次提到。他们有精通外语的人，监控国际短波广播。
And then they turned their findings into entertainment, like the hit CBS radio series hosted by a popular detective novelist named Rex Stout. It was called Our Secret Weapon. The truth is a weapon that isn't secret in our country, but it's a big secret to the people who live in Germany, Japan, and Italy. Our enemies don't have this weapon. They don't dare let their people know the truth. Every week, radio sleuth Stout debunked
然后他们把调查结果变成了娱乐节目，比如由一位受欢迎的侦探小说家雷克斯·斯托特主持的 CBS 热门广播系列节目。它叫《我们的秘密武器》。真相是一种在我们国家并不秘密的武器，但对于生活在德国、日本和意大利的人民来说，这是一个巨大的秘密。我们的敌人没有这种武器。他们不敢让人民知道真相。每周，广播侦探斯托特都会揭穿
enemy shortwave propaganda. First, a broadcast of the official German news agency on August 2nd. The meeting between Churchill and Stalin was very excited and hysterical. It assumed that... On August 8th, being that England... This morning, Churchill shook hands with Stalin at the Kremlin.
敌人的短波宣传。首先，8 月 2 日德国官方通讯社的广播。丘吉尔和斯大林之间的会晤非常激动和歇斯底里。它假设……8 月 8 日，鉴于英国……今天早上，丘吉尔在克里姆林宫与斯大林握手。
As we now know, Churchill actually arrived in Moscow on August 12th. You can't beat that for a scoop. The rest of the Allies were also busy fighting Germany's shortwave radio propaganda. It was during World War II that the BBC ramped up what would come to be known as the World Service on shortwave. This is London calling in the O.C. service of the British Broadcasting Corporation. They broadcast news to the world with just a bit of pro-ally spin.
正如我们现在所知，丘吉尔实际上是在 8 月 12 日抵达莫斯科的。你无法击败这个独家新闻。其他盟国也忙于对抗德国的短波广播宣传。正是在第二次世界大战期间，英国广播公司（BBC）加强了后来被称为短波世界服务的节目。这是伦敦在呼叫，英国广播公司的海外服务。他们向世界广播新闻，并带有一点亲盟军的色彩。
The Danes have already had a taste of what German protection means. A better word for it would be plunder, for the Germans are seizing goods and property at will. And in early 1942, the US followed suit. The federal government debuted its shortwave radio service, The Voice of America, with an in-language broadcast to Germany. Here speaks a voice from America. This is a voice speaking from America.
丹麦人已经尝到了德国保护意味着什么。用一个更好的词来形容就是掠夺，因为德国人正在随意夺取货物和财产。1942 年初，美国也效仿了这一做法。联邦政府推出了其短波广播服务——美国之音（The Voice of America），用当地语言向德国广播。这里是来自美国的声音。这是一个来自美国的声音。
Our voices are coming to you from New York, across the Atlantic Ocean to London. The Voice of America started as a government-run radio show, and they partnered with networks like NBC and CBS to get it out worldwide. NBC and CBS were already broadcasting overseas via shortwave. But shortwave quickly proved so central to the war effort that the U.S. government did something unprecedented. They nationalized all the roughly one dozen shortwave stations broadcasting from U.S. soil, filling the international airwaves with approved broadcasts.
我们的声音正从纽约传向伦敦，跨越大西洋。美国之音最初是一个政府运营的广播节目，他们与 NBC 和 CBS 等电视网合作，将其推向全球。NBC 和 CBS 已经通过短波向海外广播。但短波很快被证明对战争努力至关重要，以至于美国政府做了一件前所未有的事情。他们将从美国本土广播的大约十几家短波电台全部国有化，用经过批准的广播填满了国际广播频段。
Daily at this time, we shall speak to you about America and the war. The news may be good or bad. We shall tell you the truth. And for the most part, they did that. If a bit selectively. Michelle Hilms. They were walking a fine line between willful propaganda and sort of putting a good spin on things.
每天这个时候，我们将与您谈论美国和战争。新闻可能是好是坏。我们将告诉您真相。在大多数情况下，他们确实做到了。如果稍微有点选择性的话。米歇尔·希尔姆斯。他们在蓄意宣传和某种程度上对事情进行美化之间走钢丝。
As the U.S. sent more troops into battle, it used shortwave to boost morale. They began to transmit entertainment programming via shortwave to the troops. Susan Douglas again. And this was so important during holidays like Christmas and New Year's when there you are freezing and alone and scared. They had programs that would allow troops to speak to people back at home, you know, oh here's mailbag and we have letters from soldiers and they would read them aloud. Dear mother, tonight I'm very lonely.
随着美国派遣更多军队投入战斗，它利用短波来提振士气。他们开始通过短波向部队传输娱乐节目。苏珊·道格拉斯再次提到。这在圣诞节和新年等节日期间非常重要，因为那时你孤身一人，感到寒冷和恐惧。他们有允许部队与国内亲人通话的节目，你知道的，哦，这是“邮件袋”，我们有士兵的来信，他们会大声朗读出来。亲爱的母亲，今晚我感到非常孤独。
I've never written that before and maybe it's a shock to you. And then again maybe you've read between the lines and have known it all along. There was a very popular program called G.I. Jive with Jill. Here's Jill and the G.I. Jive. Hi, you fellas. This is G.I. Jill with G.I. Jive. You know, the World Series. The 1942 World Series broadcast.
我以前从未写过这些，也许这对你来说是个震惊。但也许你已经读出了字里行间的意思，一直都知道。有一个非常受欢迎的节目叫《吉尔的 G.I. Jive》。这是吉尔和 G.I. Jive。嗨，伙计们。我是 G.I. 吉尔，这是 G.I. Jive。你知道，世界大赛。1942 年世界大赛的广播。
You've got to have the World Series. The Voice of America was very highly respected, and many people think that it did a great deal to help us win the war. By the end of the Second World War, the Voice of America blanketed much of the world. It ran in about 40 languages. But they were about to get lots of company on the airwaves. Because in the Cold War, the short waves exploded.
你必须得听世界大赛。美国之音非常受人尊敬，许多人认为它在帮助我们赢得战争方面发挥了巨大作用。到第二次世界大战结束时，美国之音覆盖了世界大部分地区。它以大约 40 种语言播出。但他们很快就会在广播中遇到很多竞争对手。因为在冷战时期，短波爆炸式增长。
That's coming up after the break. This is On The Media. I'm Katie Thornton, host of OTM's Divided Dial series. We're right in the middle of episode one of our second season. Before the break, we heard about how groups like the VOA dominated the short waves at the end of World War II. But during the Cold War, shortwave would become so much more. Radio, in your case. This is Tehran, radio, Iran.
休息后回来继续。这里是《On The Media》。我是凯蒂·桑顿，OTM《分裂的表盘》系列的主持人。我们正处于第二季第一集的中间。休息前，我们听到了像美国之音这样的组织如何在二战结束时主导短波。但在冷战期间，短波将变得远不止于此。广播，在你的情况下。这是德黑兰，伊朗广播电台。
The Australian forces radio. You are tuned to the North American service of radio Moscow. The VOA, the BBC, the Soviet Union, China, Egypt, Iran, Argentina, and so many others were on shortwave, broadcasting their national identity to the world in stories and song. They were joined by newly decolonized nations like Libya and Ghana, whose leaders saw the shortwaves as a way to promote their independence and to fuel an international anti-colonial movement.
澳大利亚军队广播电台。您收听的是莫斯科广播电台的北美服务。美国之音、BBC、苏联、中国、埃及、伊朗、阿根廷和许多其他国家都在短波上，用故事和歌曲向世界广播他们的民族认同。他们加入了像利比亚和加纳这样新近去殖民化的国家，这些国家的领导人将短波视为促进独立和推动国际反殖民运动的一种方式。
But the global superpowers, the US and the Soviet Union, were two of the most dominant voices on shortwave. And shortwave became one of the most ferocious battlegrounds of the Cold War. At bat for the Soviet Union was Radio Moscow. Founded in 1929, the USSR's government-run network broadcast in over 70 languages. With news, propaganda, and human interest stories, it offered a Soviet alternative to the BBC and the VOA. America hit a new high in crime, and according to FBI reports to the president, nearly half of the criminals were young people. The causes of this menacing situation are well known.
但全球超级大国，美国和苏联，是短波上最占主导地位的两个声音。短波成为了冷战最激烈的战场之一。苏联的先锋是莫斯科广播电台。成立于 1929 年，苏联的政府运营网络以 70 多种语言广播。通过新闻、宣传和人文故事，它提供了 BBC 和美国之音之外的苏联选择。美国的犯罪率创下新高，根据联邦调查局给总统的报告，近一半的罪犯是年轻人。这种威胁局势的原因是众所周知的。
The pornographic pictures distributed among adolescents and the exhibitions of abstract paintings and statues that say nothing to either the heart or the mind. The BBC and the VOA were expanding too, sending more and more coverage over the Iron Curtain. But the United States government wanted to reach people in Eastern Europe with messages that weren't so obviously propaganda as the literal voice of America. So they lied.
在青少年中散布的色情图片，以及那些对心灵和思想都毫无意义的抽象画和雕像展览。BBC 和美国之音也在扩张，向铁幕后发送越来越多的报道。但美国政府希望向东欧人民传达信息，这些信息不像美国之音那样明显是宣传。所以他们撒了谎。
Radio Free Europe gets through with the truth every day. Debuting in 1950, Radio Free Europe was a flame-throwing anti-communist shortwave network. Into the closed communist countries of Poland, Czechoslovakia and Hungary, Bulgaria and Romania go the facts. The people are not allowed to hear the truth. The truth that helps them hold onto the will and the drive. It was portrayed as grassroots, run by emigres and exiles, and it did employ those folks. But secretly, it was funded by the CIA, which was busy meddling in global politics
自由欧洲电台每天都在传递真相。自由欧洲电台于 1950 年首次亮相，是一个喷火式的反共短波网络。事实进入了波兰、捷克斯洛伐克、匈牙利、保加利亚和罗马尼亚等封闭的共产主义国家。人民不被允许听到真相。帮助他们坚持意志和动力的真相。它被描绘成草根组织，由流亡者和移民经营，它确实雇佣了这些人。但秘密地，它是由中央情报局资助的，中情局在这些冷战岁月里忙于干涉全球政治
and supporting pro-capitalist coups during these Cold War years. Voila, hlas svobodneho Československa, radio svobodná Evropa. Staff at Radio Free Europe launched weather balloons into the Eastern Bloc and airdropped over 300 million leaflets instructing listeners on how to tune in. The Soviet Union did not like any of this.
并支持亲资本主义的政变。自由捷克斯洛伐克之声，自由欧洲电台。自由欧洲电台的工作人员向东方集团发射气象气球，并空投了超过 3 亿份传单，指导听众如何收听。苏联不喜欢这一切。
They spent tons of money trying to drown out Western broadcasts. They'd flood the short waves with ear-splitting noises that listeners recalled sounding like a buzz saw or a machine gun. Sometimes the battle went beyond the airwaves, like when a Czechoslovakian double agent poisoned the salt shakers at Radio Free Europe's Munich office. That plot was foiled before any of the 1,200-plus employees sat down for lunch. That plot was foiled before any of the 1,200-plus employees sat down for lunch. Years later, a Radio Free Europe journalist died after allegedly being stabbed with a poison-tipped umbrella. But these U.S.-run shortwave stations weren't just beaming out journalism.
他们花费巨资试图淹没西方广播。他们用听众回忆起来听起来像电锯或机关枪的刺耳噪音淹没短波。有时战斗超出了广播范围，比如当一名捷克斯洛伐克双重间谍在自由欧洲电台慕尼黑办公室的盐瓶里下毒时。那个阴谋在 1200 多名员工坐下来吃午饭之前就被挫败了。多年后，一名自由欧洲电台记者在据称被毒伞刺伤后死亡。但这些美国运营的短波电台不仅仅是在广播新闻。
— Willis Conover speaking. This is the Voice of America, jazz hour. The music of jazz parallels the freedom that we have in America, something that not every country has. In the 1950s and 60s, music, especially jazz, was a key component in the US government's shortwave campaign. This is the voice of America.
——威利斯·科诺弗发言。这是美国之音，爵士乐时间。爵士乐的音乐与我们在美国拥有的自由相平行，这是并非每个国家都拥有的东西。在 20 世纪 50 年代和 60 年代，音乐，尤其是爵士乐，是美国政府短波运动的关键组成部分。这是美国之音。
The federal government ran a Jazz Ambassador program that sent musicians like Louis Armstrong and Duke Ellington on tours around the world. They focused on countries that the Soviet Union was also hoping to win over. All the while though, many of these very same musicians faced racism and segregation at home. And on the short waves, Radio Moscow and others were ready to exploit this contradiction. The revolutionary people of Cuba sympathize with all people
联邦政府开展了一项“爵士大使”计划，派遣路易斯·阿姆斯特朗和艾灵顿公爵等音乐家到世界各地巡回演出。他们专注于苏联也希望争取的国家。然而，与此同时，许多这些音乐家在国内却面临着种族主义和种族隔离。而在短波上，莫斯科广播电台和其他电台准备利用这一矛盾。古巴革命人民同情所有
who struggle for social justice. In the early 1960s, Cuba's government-run service, Radio Havana, regularly beamed this show, Radio Free Dixie, up to the United States. It is in this spirit that we proudly allocate the following hour in an act of solidarity, peace, and friendship with our oppressed North American brothers. Radio Free Dixie invites you to listen to the free voice of the South. Radio Free Dixie was hosted by US Black Power activist
为社会正义而斗争的人民。在 20 世纪 60 年代初，古巴政府运营的服务——哈瓦那广播电台，经常向美国广播这个节目——《自由迪克西电台》（Radio Free Dixie）。正是本着这种精神，我们自豪地分配接下来的一个小时，作为与我们受压迫的北美兄弟团结、和平与友谊的行动。自由迪克西电台邀请您收听南方自由的声音。自由迪克西电台由美国黑人权力活动家
Robert F. Williams. He was on the lam in Cuba, fleeing drummed-up charges that were later dropped. And he broadcast a perspective that couldn't be found in the mainstream US media. One Negro goes to the White House as a member of the president's cabinet, while another is gunned down like a wild dog for using a white folks' toilet. It should be more than clear to us that if
罗伯特·F·威廉姆斯主持。他当时在古巴逃亡，躲避后来被撤销的捏造指控。他广播了一种在主流美国媒体中找不到的观点。一个黑人作为总统内阁成员进入白宫，而另一个黑人却因为使用了白人的厕所而被像野狗一样枪杀。这对我们来说应该很清楚，如果
we are ever going to be free, we must liberate ourselves. Outlets like Radio Moscow and Radio Havana won followers around the world with their mix of propaganda and just factual reporting on civil rights abuses in the U.S. Governments saw winning people over on shortwave as a key path to winning the Cold War. So even after the CIA's secretive role at Radio Free Europe was revealed in the early 70s, not much changed. In fact, Congress increased its budget, and they kept pumping out news and tunes. Increasingly, they played the defiant and oh-so-American sound of rock music, which was heavily censored in the USSR and Eastern Bloc. On the US's government-run, taxpayer-funded shortwave stations, they broadcast groups like Metallica and
我们想要获得自由，我们必须解放自己。像莫斯科广播电台和哈瓦那广播电台这样的媒体，凭借其宣传和对美国民权侵犯的事实报道，赢得了世界各地的追随者。各国政府将赢得短波听众视为赢得冷战的关键途径。因此，即使在中央情报局在自由欧洲电台的秘密角色于 70 年代初被揭露后，情况也没有太大改变。事实上，国会增加了预算，他们继续播放新闻和音乐。他们越来越多地播放反叛的、非常美国化的摇滚乐，这种音乐在苏联和东方集团受到严格审查。在美国政府运营、纳税人资助的短波电台上，他们广播了像 Metallica 和
Motley Crue to listeners around the world. By the early 1980s, the US government's shortwave stations reached an estimated 80 million people each week. It took tons of manpower, and it was a huge infrastructure project, too. The government had miles upon miles of fields filled with antennas. But one man didn't think that was enough. We're as far behind the Soviets and their allies in international broadcasting today
Motley Crue 这样的乐队给世界各地的听众。到 20 世纪 80 年代初，美国政府的短波电台每周估计覆盖 8000 万人。这需要大量的人力，也是一个巨大的基础设施项目。政府拥有数英里又数英里的布满天线的场地。但有一个人认为这还不够。我们今天在国际广播方面落后于苏联及其盟友，
as we were in space when they launched Sputnik in 1957. On the home front, Ronald Reagan had vetoed public broadcasting budgets and overseen a massive deregulation of the airwaves that allowed for big businesses and conservative and religious broadcasters to dominate AM and FM radio. You know, season one of The Divided Dial. But on international radio, on shortwave, the great deregulator had no qualms about spending taxpayer dollars. He poured public money into the VOA and Radio Free Europe. I'm pleased to call on Director Wick and Minister Filali to sign this agreement, an
就像 1957 年他们发射人造卫星时我们在太空方面落后一样。在国内，罗纳德·里根否决了公共广播预算，并监督了广播频段的大规模放松管制，允许大企业以及保守派和宗教广播公司主导 AM 和 FM 广播。你知道的，《分裂的表盘》第一季。但在国际广播上，在短波上，这位伟大的放松管制者毫不犹豫地花费纳税人的钱。他将公共资金投入到美国之音和自由欧洲电台。我很高兴邀请威克局长和菲拉利部长签署这项协议，这是
important step towards strengthening the signal of the voice of America. Reagan's administrators wrung their hands over what to do about rock music. Lots of them didn't believe it represented the best of Western culture. But after long internal debates, they decided to keep the rebellious racket going on the short waves. Meanwhile, on the journalism side, Reagan led a shakeup by sidestepping one of the voice of America's long-held tenants, the idea that a free press is the US's best advertisement. Sure, that idea hadn't always been perfectly executed,
加强美国之音信号的重要一步。里根的行政人员对如何处理摇滚乐感到焦虑。他们中的许多人认为这并不代表西方文化的精华。但在长期的内部辩论后，他们决定让这种反叛的噪音继续在短波上播放。与此同时，在新闻方面，里根通过回避美国之音长期坚持的原则之一——即自由媒体是美国最好的广告——来领导了一场改组。当然，这个想法并不总是得到完美的执行，
but Reagan opted instead for more heavy-handed anti-communist propaganda. Reagan's VOA ran explicit editorials on behalf of the administration. Many longtime leaders resigned, replaced by more amenable colleagues, including Richard W. Carlson, father of right-wing bloviator Tucker Carlson. And it was Reagan who launched a costly new shortwave service targeting Cuba with hardline anti-communist messages. Today, I'm appealing to the Congress, help us get the truth through.
但里根选择了更强硬的反共宣传。里根的美国之音代表政府发表了明确的社论。许多长期领导人辞职，取而代之的是更顺从的同事，包括理查德·W·卡尔森，右翼大嘴塔克·卡尔森的父亲。正是里根发起了一项昂贵的新短波服务，以强硬的反共信息针对古巴。今天，我呼吁国会，帮助我们将真相传达出去。
Support our proposal for a new radio station, Radio Marti, for broadcasting to Cuba. While public broadcasting floundered at home, government subsidized propaganda and bad hair metal reverberated on shortwave from the US to the world. In its first seven decades of life, shortwave transformed from an idealistic experiment in global cooperation into a hardened government tool of information warfare. And then in the late 1980s, much of the medium's reason for being crumbled. In Eastern Europe, which the Soviets had held by force since World War II, Mikhail Gorbachev said that Moscow would no longer interfere.
支持我们关于建立一个新电台——马蒂广播电台（Radio Marti）——向古巴广播的提议。当公共广播在国内挣扎时，政府补贴的宣传和糟糕的重金属音乐从美国通过短波传向世界。在它生命的最初七十年里，短波从一个全球合作的理想主义实验转变为一个强硬的政府信息战工具。然后在 20 世纪 80 年代末，这种媒介存在的大部分理由崩溃了。在苏联自二战以来一直以武力控制的东欧，米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫表示，莫斯科将不再干涉。
Serious fighting begins in the early morning. A staccato of machine gun bursts punctuated by cannon fire. In the last weeks and months, we've seen one Communist Party after the other released in Europe knocked off its perch by the people. The Cold War was over. On this medium that seemed almost tailor-made for propaganda, there was vacancy, airtime for rent. And in the US, a particular group of people was ready to snatch it up.
激烈的战斗在清晨开始。机关枪的断续声被炮火声打断。在过去的几周和几个月里，我们看到欧洲一个又一个共产党政权被人民推翻。冷战结束了。在这种似乎是为宣传量身定做的媒介上，出现了空缺，有出租的广播时间。而在美国，一群特定的人准备抢占它。
You must form your militia unit. Say no heed to the federal government, which is a counterfeit enemy foreign government. Are you a white woman such as myself who is sick of being harassed and tormented? Call Aryan nations for a whiter, brighter America. We don't want to have to kill you, we hope to not have to kill you, but we can kill you, and if need be we will kill you. Well, what are a few lives in the grand scheme of liberty? I'm sure you are now seeing the reports of some things that are regularly said
你必须组建你的民兵单位。不要理会联邦政府，那是一个伪造的敌对外国政府。你是否像我一样，是一位厌倦了被骚扰和折磨的白人女性？致电雅利安国，为了一个更白、更光明的美国。我们不想杀死你，我们希望不必杀死你，但我们可以杀死你，如果需要，我们会杀死你。好吧，在自由的宏大蓝图中，几条生命算什么？我相信你现在已经看到了经常在今天美国的广播中说的一些事情的报道。
over the airwaves in America today. These stations and the programs grew and they took over. They dominated. What is associated in the public's mind was shortwave. It's no longer the BBC World Service. Now it's the guys who helped Timothy McVeigh bomb a federal building. Next time on The Divided Dial, it's the shortwave story you've never heard.
这些电台和节目不断发展，最终占据了主导地位。它们统治了一切。公众心目中与之相关的是短波。它不再是英国广播公司世界服务部。现在，它是那些帮助蒂莫西·麦克维炸毁联邦大楼的人。下期《分裂的表盘》，讲述你从未听过的短波故事。
The private citizens who took over a fringe medium with a fringe message and used it to build a movement that fundamentally changed mainstream US politics. Katie Thornton, it's so nice to have you back on the show. I love that episode. Thank you so much, Roman. It's great to be here. Thanks for having me back. I'm so excited to hear the rest of this series. So what made you want to do a series on shortwave radio
那些接管了一个边缘媒介并利用边缘信息建立了一个从根本上改变美国主流政治运动的普通公民。凯蒂·桑顿，很高兴你回到节目中。我喜欢那一集。非常感谢你，罗曼。很高兴来到这里。谢谢你邀请我回来。我非常兴奋能听到这个系列的其余部分。那么是什么让你想做一个关于短波广播的系列节目呢？
at this moment, which is not the peak of shortwave radio usage, but it's something that is so fascinating and so cool? Yeah, it's definitely not the peak of shortwave radio usage. The internet really sort of took a bite out of it. But I was really interested in shortwave radio in part because I love radio and I had never really heard much about shortwave. I started volunteering at FM radio stations when I was in my teens. I worked at them throughout my teens and 20s.
在这一刻，虽然这不是短波广播使用的巅峰时期，但它却如此迷人且酷？是的，这绝对不是短波广播使用的巅峰时期。互联网确实在某种程度上蚕食了它。但我对短波广播非常感兴趣，部分原因是我热爱广播，而且我以前从未真正听说过太多关于短波的事情。我在十几岁时就开始在调频广播电台做志愿者。我在十几岁和二十多岁时一直在这些电台工作。
I obviously still make radio today. Like I love radio. I love what it can do. I love that it moves through the air at the speed of light and it magically shows up in a box in your kitchen or your car or wherever. I think it's just sort of this magical thing. And yet, I had never really heard about shortwave. And a friend of mine, after the first season of The Divided Dial came out, a friend of
我显然今天还在制作广播。就像我热爱广播一样。我热爱它能做的事情。我热爱它以光速在空气中传播，并神奇地出现在你厨房、汽车或任何地方的盒子里。我认为这简直是一种神奇的东西。然而，我以前从未真正听说过短波。我的一个朋友，在《分裂的表盘》第一季播出后，我的一个朋友
mine was like, hey, do you know about this station? It's like really powerful. It reaches every continent. It's like a shortwave radio station. And I remember thinking, shortwave, is that still a thing? That's like that Cold War medium, right? That's the only context I had for it.
对我说，嘿，你知道这个电台吗？它非常强大。它覆盖了每一个大陆。它就像一个短波广播电台。我记得当时想，短波，那还是个东西吗？那不是冷战时期的媒介吗？那是我对它的唯一了解。
And so I really wanted to find out what the history was, what it's like today, and some weird stuff that's going to be coming up in the future on the ShoreWaves. So one of the things you mentioned very briefly in the episode we just heard is something I'm completely fascinated by, and that is QSL cards. So first of all, can you describe what a QSL card is, again, for people who are unfamiliar?
所以我真的很想找出它的历史是什么，今天是什么样子，以及未来在短波上会出现的一些奇怪的事情。所以你在我们刚刚听到的那一集中非常简短地提到的事情之一是我完全着迷的事情，那就是QSL卡。所以首先，你能再次为不熟悉的人描述一下什么是QSL卡吗？
Yeah, absolutely. A QSL card is almost like a combination thank you card and postcard that broadcasters send out. So they really started sort of in the late teens and early 20s when amateur radio operators were first starting to send their signals across the country, across national borders, across the world. And they wanted to know how far they were reaching. Natural curiosity, you've got this new technology, you're bouncing it off the ionosphere, you're like, where
是的，绝对可以。QSL卡几乎就像是广播公司寄出的感谢卡和明信片的结合体。它们确实是在十年代末和二十年代初开始出现的，当时业余无线电操作员刚开始将信号发送到全国、跨越国界、跨越世界。他们想知道他们能达到多远。出于自然的好奇心，你有了这种新技术，你把它从电离层反射回来，你会想，哪里
can you hear me? And so these people who were out there on the short waves, they would basically say, hey, if you're hearing this, please write me a letter, please tell me where you are, please tell me what you're listening on, and what did you think of the program? Did it come through pretty clear? Things like that. So the listeners would send these letters, and the people who were putting the transmissions out there would send them these beautifully decorated cards as sort of thank you notes
能听到我？所以这些在短波上的人，他们基本上会说，嘿，如果你听到了这个，请给我写封信，请告诉我你在哪里，请告诉我你在用什么听，你觉得这个节目怎么样？它传过来很清楚吗？诸如此类的事情。所以听众会寄这些信，而那些进行传输的人会寄给他们这些装饰精美的卡片作为感谢信
back. The broadcaster got information about just how far their signal was reaching and the listener got to sort of amass this collection that really showed off like, here's how good I am at listening to the radio. I have all these cards from all over the world and they're all incredible. So before we talk about the sort of design of the physical cards themselves, what does QSL actually stand for? Yeah, great question.
作为回馈。广播公司得到了关于他们的信号能达到多远的信息，而听众则能够积累这种真正展示出“看，我听广播有多厉害”的收藏。我有所有来自世界各地的这些卡片，它们都令人难以置信。所以在我们谈论物理卡片本身的设计之前，QSL到底代表什么？是的，好问题。
The one that I had as well and was slightly disappointed by the answer. It's not an abbreviation. It's just part of this what's called Q code. It's an international code that's basically an assortment of three letters, Q followed by two other letters, and then they mean something. Like if you're transmitting in Morse code, QSL, and on shortwave, QSL means I confirm receipt
这也是我有的问题，而且对答案感到有点失望。它不是缩写。它只是所谓的Q代码的一部分。它是一种国际代码，基本上是三个字母的组合，Q后面跟着另外两个字母，然后它们代表某种含义。就像如果你在用摩尔斯电码传输，QSL，在短波上，QSL意味着我确认收到
of your transmission. And so it's sort of like a shorthand for the same way you would hear on CB radio truckers communicating with one one another like 10-4, things like that. Yeah, it's like a little language. So I've seen collections of these QSL cards and they're really beautiful. So could you describe to the audience what they look like? Yeah, they really are so beautiful. I mean, some of them are quite simple. They have like your handle for the amateur radio operators in particular. They'll have like, you know, you have a series of letters and numbers that you go by on the radio. It's like your licensed name.
你的传输。所以它有点像速记，就像你在CB电台听到卡车司机互相交流时说“10-4”之类的。是的，它就像一种小语言。所以我见过这些QSL卡的收藏，它们真的很漂亮。所以你能向听众描述一下它们看起来是什么样的吗？是的，它们确实非常漂亮。我的意思是，其中一些相当简单。它们有你的代号，特别是对于业余无线电操作员来说。它们会有，你知道，你有一系列字母和数字，你在广播中使用。这就像你的执照名称。
And so some of them are just sort of that just that plain text. But some people would decorate their cards super beautifully, you know, something personal to them or personal from where they were broadcasting from. But the people who like really went wild with the decorations were the broadcast stations. So on radio, you have one-to-one transmission. That would be a lot of amateur operators. They're just trying to make contact from one person to another person across a vast distance.
所以其中一些只是那种纯文本。但有些人会把他们的卡片装饰得超级漂亮，你知道，一些对他们个人有意义的东西，或者来自他们广播的地方的个人特色。但那些真正疯狂装饰的人是广播电台。所以在广播中，你有一对一的传输。那将是很多业余操作员。他们只是试图从一个人到另一个人进行跨越巨大距离的联系。
But starting in the 20s, you started to have broadcasting on shortwave. So that's from one to many. It's actually a term that early broadcasters borrowed from agriculture. Like when you broadcast seeds, you basically scatter seeds all over the place. So you're just trying to hit as many people,
但从20年代开始，你开始在短波上进行广播。所以那是一对多。这实际上是早期广播公司从农业中借用的一个术语。就像当你播种时，你基本上把种子撒得到处都是。所以你只是试图接触尽可能多的人，
in the case of radio broadcasting, as possible. And so after, there were some early AM stations that ended up transmitting their signal on shortwave and getting into different countries. And a lot of these stations, especially by the 30s and the 40s, were owned by governments. And so a lot of the broadcast stations, a lot of which are run by governments, they went wild with the decorations on the QSLs. But yeah, these stations would really use the QSL cards as an opportunity to paint a picture of how they wanted their home country to be perceived and understood on the global stage. Matthew Feeney Yeah. And they're kind of like tourist picture postcards. They have maps and they have, you know,
在广播的情况下，尽可能多的人。所以之后，有一些早期的AM电台最终在短波上发送信号并进入不同的国家。而这些电台中的许多，特别是在30年代和40年代，都是由政府拥有的。所以很多广播电台，其中许多是由政府运营的，它们在QSL的装饰上非常疯狂。但是是的，这些电台确实会利用QSL卡作为一个机会，来描绘他们希望他们的祖国在全球舞台上被感知和理解的形象。马修·费尼 是的。它们有点像旅游明信片。它们有地图，它们有，你知道，
highlight highlighted features of the landscape and things like that. They're really beautiful. Absolutely. They're so beautiful. They are like postcards. Like imagine if the official government tourism bureau was like, we will make a postcard
突出显示的景观特征等等。它们真的很漂亮。绝对的。它们太漂亮了。它们就像明信片。就像想象一下，如果官方政府旅游局说，我们将制作一张明信片
to represent everything about our country in one image. That's sort of what they were trying to do with the QSLs. It was almost sort of like an element of this broader soft power campaign. Like, how do we want to broadcast ourselves not just in sound, but in imagery to the rest of the world? So there's beautiful maps.
用一张图片来代表我们国家的一切。这正是他们试图用QSL卡做的事情。它几乎就像是这种更广泛的软实力运动的一个要素。就像，我们不仅想在声音上，而且想在形象上向世界其他地方广播我们自己？所以有漂亮的地图。
There's food items. There's clothing that is specific to regions. There was a lot of architectural feats would maybe be depicted sometimes in an artistic style that was specific to that country. They're colorful, they're beautiful, the fonts are amazing to watch change over time. One of the things that I love about these QSLs is how many of them have radio imagery. They're all so excited about the fact that they're using radio, especially the ones from the 30s, 40s, and 50s. They all have that sort of early radio graphic of the lightning bolts, which to me is so cool
有食物。有特定于地区的服装。有很多建筑壮举有时会被描绘出来，也许是以该国特有的艺术风格。它们色彩鲜艳，它们很漂亮，字体随着时间的推移而变化，看起来非常棒。我喜欢这些QSL卡的一点是，它们中有多少带有无线电图像。它们都对自己在利用无线电感到非常兴奋，特别是30年代、40年代和50年代的那些。它们都有那种早期的无线电图形，即闪电，这对我来说太酷了
because it was like, how do you demonstrate the power and the excitement of this invisible thing? It's like, obviously it's got to be lightning bolts. Soterios Johnson And so what is the status of QSL cards today? Like, is this still something people do? I imagine they're collector's items because QSL cards today? Like, is this still something people do? I imagine they're collector's items because the world of shortwave is a very, I don't know, it's a very like active subculture
因为就像是，你如何展示这种无形事物的力量和兴奋感？就像，显然它必须是闪电。索特里奥斯·约翰逊 那么QSL卡今天的地位如何？就像，这仍然是人们做的事情吗？我想它们是收藏品，因为QSL卡今天？就像，这仍然是人们做的事情吗？我想它们是收藏品，因为短波世界是一个非常，我不知道，它是一个非常活跃的亚文化
of very dedicated people. Yes, absolutely it is, absolutely it is. And it is still active. Like, certainly they're collector's items. These are like beautiful historic objects really. But there are still QSL cards that are going out today. I talked to a ton of people, a ton of broadcasters, a ton of listeners, and I was at a station where I was going through the QSL letters, the initial letter where somebody's asking
由非常专注的人组成。是的，绝对是，绝对是。而且它仍然很活跃。当然，它们是收藏品。这些确实是美丽的历史物品。但今天仍然有QSL卡在发出。我和很多人谈过，很多广播公司，很多听众，我当时在一个电台，我正在查看QSL信件，最初的信件，有人在询问
for a card. I was going through them with the station owner, and they had gotten letters from all over the place, from the US and far beyond. And so, you know, I was going through this stack of letters where it's like, here's what I heard. Here's how the reception was. And then in turn, he would mail back the station's QSL. You know, it's down from its heyday, just like a lot of things in the shortwave world
一张卡片。我和电台老板一起查看它们，他们收到了来自各地的信件，来自美国和更远的地方。所以，你知道，我正在查看这堆信件，上面写着，这是我听到的。这是接收情况。然后反过来，他会寄回电台的QSL。你知道，它比鼎盛时期有所下降，就像短波世界里的很多事情一样
are, but it's still very much happening today, which is really neat. So before we wrap up, could you tell me a little bit more about the whole series and where it's headed from here? Yeah, well, the second episode is dropping May 14th. This next episode is really going to dive into the pretty little known role that shortwave radio played in the rise of the American right, especially sort of in the 90s and into the 2000s. We're also going to go visit a very particular, peculiar station operating out of the US,
但它今天仍然非常活跃，这真的很棒。所以在我们结束之前，你能多告诉我一点关于整个系列以及它从这里走向何方吗？是的，好吧，第二集将于5月14日发布。下一集将真正深入探讨短波广播在美国右翼崛起中扮演的鲜为人知的角色，特别是在90年代和2000年代。我们还将去参观一个非常特别、奇特的在美国运营的电台，
one of the most powerful broadcasting facilities on the planet that I did not know existed until quite recently, and play some very interesting material. And then we end the series, the fourth episode, by talking about what's going on in the short waves today and what's happening in the future on the short waves. Because as I talk to people, I learned that there is a battle going on on the short waves right now that is really representative, I think says a lot about how we value or don't value our public air waves. Well, I'm so glad that the series is back. The first series of The Divided Dial was amazing. It won a Peabody Award.
地球上最强大的广播设施之一，直到最近我才知道它的存在，并播放一些非常有趣的材料。然后我们以第四集结束这个系列，谈论今天短波上正在发生的事情以及未来在短波上会发生什么。因为当我与人们交谈时，我了解到短波上现在正在进行一场战斗，我认为这非常有代表性，说明了我们如何重视或不重视我们的公共广播。好吧，我很高兴这个系列又回来了。《分裂的表盘》第一系列太棒了。它赢得了皮博迪奖。
And now I'm so excited to hear the second season. And it's all going to be released on the media's podcast feed and on the airwaves. So thank you so much for being back with us. Thank you so much for having me. It was great to talk with you about this. The Divided Dial was created by Katie Thornton and WNYC's having me. It was great to talk with you about this. The Divided Dial was created by Katie Thornton and WNYC's On the Media, edited by OTM's executive producer, Katja Rogers
现在我非常兴奋能听到第二季。它都将在媒体的播客源和广播中发布。所以非常感谢你回到我们这里。非常感谢你邀请我。和你谈论这个真是太好了。《分裂的表盘》由凯蒂·桑顿和WNYC的《媒体观察》创作，由OTM执行制片人卡佳·罗杰斯编辑
with music and sound design by Jared Paul. The series is also supported by the Fund for Investigative Journalism. 99PI's executive producer is Cathy Tu, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason De Leon, Joe Rosenberg, Martine Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Bosch Madon, Swan Rial, Jacob Medina-Coleason and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
音乐和声音设计由贾里德·保罗负责。该系列也得到了调查新闻基金的支持。99PI的执行制片人是凯西·图，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德·莱昂、乔·罗森伯格、马丁·冈萨雷斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、博世·马登、斯旺·里亚尔、雅各布·梅迪纳-科利森和我罗曼·马斯。99%的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。
We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. We're all over blue sky and our Discord server is thriving. We'll have links to those as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。而且很漂亮。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们遍布蓝天，我们的Discord服务器非常繁荣。我们将在99PI.org上提供这些链接以及99PI的每一集过往节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。